all right we could all use a little
extra cash right of course yeah whether
it's just to make your monthly bills or
because you want to beef up your fund
for the holiday spending season if you
are considering gig work there are some
important things to know
it seems everywhere you look these days
now hiring signs are posted in all sorts
of businesses retail you're talking
about Hospitality hotels events delivery
fulfillment centers all of those
different Industries and all of those
different employers need help right now
Alex Atwood is the CEO of gravy work an
app that matches employers with workers
who can work either just a single day
shift or multiple days across an event
gig work offers a great opportunity for
someone to make some extra cash to buy
those holiday gifts to make the process
most efficient at would suggest you set
your availability in advance so you can
plan your commitments so take a look at
your calendar over the next few months
and really determine what you know what
times you have available where you can
work these extra jobs be flexible and
open-minded git work is fast paced
sometimes more demanding that a
traditional job you need to prepare
yourself for long hours and possibly a
lot of stress with a lot of people you
know showing up to whether you're
working an event or whether you're
working in retail there's going to be a
high volume and there's going to be a
need to get things done in a short
amount of time also remember you have to
dress for the occasion holiday gigs can
require festive attire sometimes even
formal attire
the Secretary of Labor reported that
upwards of 55 million people or
one-third of the total labor force that
is engaged in some form of gig work over
the past five years